how are you coach good morning good
morning to you so let me just bounce
this one off you first before we get to
the playoffs do you think there's any
there there in New England with what has
been reported with Belichick and Brady
in the coach just knowing how
conversations can turn sideways behind
the closed doors and be kept from the
public coach yeah I mean when you're
when you're talking a relationship that
spans 18 years we're talking about craft
Brady and Belichick and it's productive
and successful it's been still I mean
it's like being married for 18 years at
some point something you say or do maybe
doesn't quite set with you and when
you're talking about three people not
just two but three when you talk about
the owner the head coach in and a star
player any number of these things you
know that the two biggest issues appear
to be one the trading of Jimmy Garoppolo
which to me is kind of like nobody wants
to do it but you kind of have to if
you've got a quarterback the level of
Tom Brady's and thinks he's going to
play for a couple more years and
certainly based on what he's done this
year it's hard I'm not going to be the
one to say no no you're done but that
relationship between but you're probably
close to being done so we're going to
keep this guy around and what's it going
to cost to keep him you know he may not
have gotten one of those hundred million
dollar contracts like he's gonna get
from San Francisco but he wasn't going
to get chump change to stick around to
wait for Brady to leave so it's kind of
one of those things well we really don't
have a lot of choice now I mean I'm sure
crap didn't want to do it I'm sure
Belichick didn't want to do it Brady was
probably pretty ambivalent to it so
however it came down however it was
communicated and in terms of Brady's guy
being around when I was leaving coaching
that was just beginning when the
personal train every got their first
their own personal guys just like when
they need surgery right what do they do
they go to some specialist they don't go
to the to the team doctors that they
work with every day it's a facility they
fly off and see Andrews or one of these
other guys for a special it's just just
what players do well they all have their
individual workout gurus and we had to
make the decision well do we say no
you you know we want you to work on our
facility with our guys of course they
have the right in the offseason to say
no no I'm gonna go over with my guy so
you can let them do that or you can let
that guy in the building so at least now
you can monitor what's going on and it
sounds like that's what they were doing
now that that stresses you a little bit
that stresses the training staff
entrusted stresses the weight coaches
and now everybody wants to do that so I
can see where that becomes a bit of a
contention but my guess is this is much
ado about nothing in terms of the rift
it's just a matter of them sorting
through well okay this is the way we're
going to operate they're in a tough spot
as having Tom Brady you sure quarterback
can be no sure but let's remember what
happened with Troy Aikman and how that
ended and they kept extending and
extending extending and once he was done
all that dead money that cost him but
took him a couple years to kind of
regroup from it and and and know
England's kind of looking at the same
thing with Brady so this is not an easy
dynamic so let me ask you this before we
move on to the playoffs ton Brian
Billick here on the Rich Eisen show as
you and I are sitting here and talking
and it could change in five minutes
the Giants job is still open okay so if
you are Bill Belichick sitting there in
a quiet moment and you say okay I'm
gonna lose both my coordinators it seems
I got to get new coordinators anyway
I've got a 41 year old quarterback who's
here with no succession plan in place
now because I flipped Garoppolo and it
might be because he was told to do it I
could stay here with the owner and the
situation that I know completely well
and I know I'm gonna have run of the
place eventually or still or I can go
back to a spot where I used to be finish
up and show I can win a championship
elsewhere I've got the number two
overall pick and I've got owners that I
know would appreciate me although a
general manager I've never worked with
which one would be more attractive to
you Brian yeah all of the above because
all those are kind of a win-win but you
have to choose one this is sports talk
radio Brian you have to choose that one
no no I'm with the media now I can talk
out the side of my mouth and names and
we'll do this tomorrow and I'll just
choose the other one nice yeah human
nature says why would you not say I mean
me
no matter what he does it's not going to
check changes like he's going to be a
slam dunk but maybe at this point if I'm
63 yada yada years old I've been here
for 18 years I've won multiple
championships maybe win another one this
year the legacy of you know what maybe
it is time to go to a place the Big
Apple be that only coach to win Super
Bowls at different places I still have
Eli Manning there and I have a top pick
to get maybe one of these young
quarterbacks and group has just set the
floor you know that's that's that's
where the negotiations begin and and and
you got to know that if I if I'm talking
is Bill Belichick now if I go to New
York with ownership that I respect and
like that general manager is working for
me now it's real simple and it's gonna
be my way yeah I could see where that's
attractive yeah and of course we are
this is pure complete supposition we
have no idea he could be under contract
for the next five years anyway Brian
Billick here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk about the playoffs then which
game leaves out at you from the schedule
well I you know they're all interesting
games I love this weekend best weekend
in football really yeah because I love
what these things are about it tells you
kind of the direction that we're going
the old established teams or guys you
know like a break Brady and a breeze and
a Roethlisberger and and then the new
and up-and-coming guys you know I'm you
mention the fact of the years I was in
Minnesota I've got a soft spark spot in
my heart for Minnesota I think that I
think the Minnesota Vikings at home
against the Atlanta Falcons I think
whoever wins this game is going to win
the NFC Championship I'd love to see
Minnesota in the championship game in
Minneapolis you know we just did a
segment on PlayBook on Wednesday this
defense is something special in
Minneapolis in Minnesota that Zimmer's
got going that game is going to be
fascinating to me you know tendency
going into New England
it's uphill battle how well does Mariota
play particularly on third down you know
and Jacksonville and Pittsburgh this
should be a one-sided game but it should
have been one Pittsburgh loss 30 deny
then rot you know at Ben Roth forgets
Blake bortles Blake board
that was a pathetic performance a
quarterback as I've seen a long time and
a thing or two about pathetic
quarterbacks having lived through it you
know so that that that one that one's
going to be interesting it should be
Pittsburgh all the way so yeah I I think
that I think that Minnesota Atlanta
games going to be the one I'm really
gonna keep an eye on do you think
bortles is playing scared Brian I think
bortles is playing in the only way he
knows he doesn't he just can't binstock
you because coming out we all kind of
thought mortals looks to me done maybe
then the next Ventura office burger yet
kind of that quality about him in the
size and the way he moved around
whatever I just I don't know what I
don't think it's scared I just think his
his his mind and his confidence is
writing checks that his arm can't
deliver on his in accuracy is stunning
to me at this point it doesn't appear to
be getting any better
and I think in Pittsburgh you know the
game in Pittsburgh because the five
interceptions you just got to throw out
the you got to throw out that out
because obviously no one's going to win
thrown five interceptions let's remember
Jack still ran for 230 yards that day so
that's probably the bigger challenge I
can't see Blake bortles in a straight-up
game where they don't get a bunch of
short fields because of the
interceptions I can't see Blake bortles
doing a lot against the Pittsburgh
defense ask the poll question of Brian
Billick well and knowing that Blake
bortles won't win this poll when he
answers the question Chris Brockman
would give it give it up to him Brian
which quarterback is gonna have the best
game this weekend looking at the non
super star quarterbacks Case Keenum Nick
Foles Mariota Blake bortles yeah
interesting that's the thing I find so
fascinating about this playoff is
because and right from the get-go
because at the top and particularly in
the NFC at the top end you have just the
thing you're alluding to foils or holes
keenum you can even throw in back last
week to Jared Goff but at the bottom in
the NFC is hall-of-famer Drew Brees Matt
Ryan who thing continues on the path
could be in that conversation and Cam
Newton that that's kind of interesting
that the bottom end of the
the free agency or the the wild card
teams going into it what that's where
all the you know quarterbacks are
playing
I think Case Keenum with that defense
and and although and llantas defense was
playing very very well other than that
that lost the Carolina where he had the
two interceptions he didn't throw an
interception the last two months of the
season and it's going to be at home
they've got the big place with feel and
digs
I think Case Keenum could have the
biggest game Brian always appreciate it
let's chat again soon thanks again take
care that's at coach Billick and that
was a coach conversation brought to you
by a man versus food you know Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience